stop the racism and homophobia this is
what I want to make sure that we are not
saying the things we shouldn't be saying
when the cameras I just want to clarify
wait it's live we're doing it live
what's that mean oh yeah okay
we're gonna film and edit so what are
those what are the rules can we curse
um
wait a little bit are we live can you
guys in the comments tell us if you can
hear us yeah live we are definitely live
so it says here Live 36 seconds so I
don't like there's no intro there's no
fun thing it's just us being confused
about being live I said I don't want to
do this it's a classic intro I see Paul
panicking already
close all my windows
all right here we go let's do a proper
intro I guess
um what is up there reject Nation we are
here today joined by the wonderful who
should get credit first heavy spoilers
or screen Crush let's let's go screen
Crush into heavy spoilers okay fine
screen Crush Ryan Airy is joining us
today
wow look at that handsome devil can you
pull off some of those uh DVDs behind
you there Ryan
I'm not going to pull off anything on
this camera no way that's a really
important for you to even ask wait
tonight yes and there right Ryan is
risking his job at the video store right
now by live streaming on the clock so be
generous the stores the store is closed
for the day Doug isn't around so I'm
just wearing my normal stuff with my
name is not on the stream this is this
we're all gonna overlap each other
and then uh let's let's all give a
moment of silence here as we introduce
the king of them all the spoilerific man
the heavy spoilers The Paul's last name
I never learned in fall
how are you doing there baby we out yeah
we do net we do it Green Team Green I'm
Team Green you know Trader go with the
winners so uh right now it's uh what 3
P.M for you Ryan and then 8 P.M for Paul
in the UK and um
are higher ups over at Zero edition they
give us some loose talking points it's
very loose we're going to keep it really
really simple really natural and fresh
but we're not going to only just talk
about that but yeah uh we teamed up
because uh there's this company called
Zero edition if you want to express your
inner geek it's the best way to do it
and right now we all have some new T's
we got Paul here with this better call
Paul shirt
need some spoilers I'm in my baby better
call Paul pull less spoilers he's seen
them all I just want to say did you I
remember in the group chat pitching that
and I never got credit for that did you
really I did I did that as an intro like
two years ago on a better cold sore
video you're not some genius who's come
up with better call Paul you're a nice
guy
you know what I mean you ain't lucky to
beat me at that this is the real rejects
Channel you don't talk that way to me
here you blocked
and then he will break out into his
Robert Baratheon voice at some point and
then we got Ryan Airy here with his not
the bees shirt
oh
I got not the bees yeah I think Nicholas
Cage should get royalties for that yeah
absolutely you know I mean you're going
after the wrong guy here Greg can we get
a Nicholas Cage shop at Zero edition
you're gonna get in legal trouble there
Ryan the Zero edition boy the team's
gonna need it I mean it just I don't
know why you guys are talking I don't
know what you guys were talking about I
just thought it was a funny image of
some some words inside a cage with some
bees around it I yeah why is it in
reference to something else
shirt here that we have overplugged so
much of the time now um according to
here we should have had a contest going
uh whoever sells the most shirts yeah
yeah whoever you like the best go to the
shops and uh show your support
and that's why heavy spoilers
what is the and to bring up that point
if if you are watching screen Crush
Nation go out buy it not the B shirt so
we can beat these guys then you can
return them later that's fine but the
main thing is we have to beat heavy
spoilers at least it's a shirt thing he
can get more views than us on any other
video but we have to sell more not the B
shirts if you do every not to be sure
you buy guarantees that Mephisto won't
return to Earth for like a year so we're
gonna keep my fist Away by buying not
the B shirts guys as I've been told that
if I sell more shirts and Ryan I get to
keep Doug so you know as your decision
if you you know who to support now you
know what to do give Doug a real home
he's working 70 hours a week in that
video still wearing that Polo [ __ ] get
him out of there we all love dogs we all
want them free get get them out buy buy
heavy spoilers better call Paul baby
you're on the real rejects Channel you
should just buy our shirts because let's
face it they're doing better than both
of us they're their channels are just
way more successful we really we needed
this is a desperate plea you've got most
of us than me though do you think that
matters let's not compare Channel views
right now
let's do it live here on the channel but
uh yeah that's it's a great way to
support the channel but what we what do
we really want to talk about here today
guys what's going on thread count what's
going on in this guy
yeah I just want to I would I just want
to talk about the wide variety of shirts
we have this one just this one shirt
so many different ones with high thread
count and different colors sizes we
might get a v-neck sometime soon you
don't know
this is our Orange
I would like we have some experimental
pet shirts though for for Doug and for
the socks to wear so you know might be
rolling out some dog shirts every now
and then you never know so we're not
talking about anything else
because I'll talk about something else I
mean with six minutes something really
big did like just happened sorry people
watching yeah Ryan what what is this MCU
news that uh just broke yeah I'm seeing
here I just saw this from uh Eric Voss
on Twitter or what friend Eric over
there at new rockstars just announced
Marvel Studio delays I don't know if he
announced them he probably got it from
somewhere else that announced it but I
saw Eric's Suite first so he gets the
credit that's blade good so they delayed
the movies
yeah exactly blade was delayed to
September 6 2024. that's not a surprise
because we already heard the directors
out and rehearsal Ali wasn't happy with
the script so that's not a surprise the
thing is though in the MCU that kicks
everything back right so and I got a
question for you guys about this next
one Deadpool 3 is delayed to November
8th 2024. is this the actual first
confirmation we have like from I know
that like Ryan Reynolds did the
announcement with Hugh Jackman and said
Deadpool 3 is happening but did we get
like a Marvel date announcement too did
I miss it yeah at the end of the trailer
did you not see the trailer
I'm always too busy making the thing
right all right so Fantastic Four also
delayed
and this this one breaks my heart
Fantastic Four was delayed 2025. the
really sad one here is Untitled Marvel
film was delayed to November 7th 2025.
I'm really curious what you guys think
that is well the kickers
Kang Dynasty
kangaskain at May 2nd 2025 but Secret
Wars is delayed to the next year to May
2026 and I think was was it originally
just going to be in the same year but in
the fall yeah is that like six months
right right which those got like
Infinity war and end game was the
perfect release time I think because
there was a a yeah a solid year of hype
I think it was almost the same date that
end game released
um just a year of solid hype YouTube has
making constant Theory videos all the
time uh and I didn't understand why they
were doing it the same year but yeah
give it give it a year I am a bit gutted
because I was planning on quitting after
Secret Wars no you know not quitting
like
heavy spoilers will still be a thing but
you'll have Jared instead or someone
else maybe Ryan yeah we're we're also
guarded because we were looking forward
to you quitting so yeah everyone was
they want me dead I don't actually ever
really quick I can't see you
relinquishing control no yeah I think
the day after I quit I'd be like I could
really do making a video right now
yeah but you'll be you'll just make
videos about your kids or like whatever
else you fancy it doesn't have to be
fancy you know people click on yeah
start a family Vlog that's a dynasty
yeah I mean do you guys think this blade
movie is going to be a piece of [ __ ]
because it sounds like it's shaping up
to not be that good if they're delay in
it then that gives me hope I mean you
know what I mean it ain't morbius
so I mean that got delayed a lot of
times
um it's not I wouldn't class it it's a
personally I think get rid of some of
the Disney Plus shows because it's clear
that I mean how many delays have Marvel
had recently it feels like every six
months they announced a delay I think
Multiverse of Madness had a delay and
then that had a knock-on effect with
everything else
um in some of the Disney Plus shows I'm
thinking look
if stuff's getting in the way you know I
mean like Ryan we've had really busy
weeks sometimes where we've been
covering a show
and it's been like uh I think I might
have to drop it this week because it's
going to have a massive knocking effect
and we're not making millions of dollars
you know what I mean so like the delays
are probably good for the the projects
themselves but I'm hoping that someone
goes we've delayed quite a lot of things
do not think we should pump the brakes
and
just do less projects
because I'm feeling a bit worn out with
marble at the moment and I'm making
money from it as well you know what I
mean if your views probably wouldn't be
worn out you know I think it really went
down to I think if your views were
higher you probably wouldn't be uh worn
out on them no I would be I 100 would be
just yeah I think it's just the
circumstances of the views that's what
you're uh you're just better if your
worth is determined because bitter yeah
I'm not I'm with you as far as like
cutting back shows as long as it's
affecting quality so like I think
overall like Marvel's still doing a lot
of things very right where you can where
you can kind of start to see the seams
like Fray a little bit is like Ms Marvel
first two episodes fantastic it ended
really strong but boy those middle as
soon as the Gin were introduced you
could see like the budget cuts the gym
like they had no powers it was just like
it felt cheap
where she's yelling at her at the portal
and she's like don't and then the
agenda's like you're right and she just
like has this the quickest face turn
I've seen outside of pro wrestling you
know so that kind of made me go oh
that's a little uh and then She-Hulk
obviously I think the scripts are great
except for episode seven but obviously
the VFX artists across Hollywood are
stretched to their limits so you're
starting to see the quality kind of go
there to the point where I kind of think
that once She-Hulk is in a movie you
might see Disney go back and like patch
the series you know yeah because we've
seen that happen on other Disney Plus
shows you know so where the quality
starts to strain I say pump the brakes
um but if a show is different to produce
like I don't think the Echo Show is
necessarily going to be VFX heavy and
Echo for all I know could be like a
really cool dark grounded Series so
maybe we don't cut Echo because that
doesn't affect the Productions of
everything else but something like I
don't know what else is what other
Disney Plus shows like Moon night when
Moon Knight was actually in it it was a
very VFX heavy show you know so maybe
shows like that they have to go like
armor Wars maybe this should be a movie
instead of a show
yeah no and I wouldn't mind if they were
like we'll turn this into a movie or
werewolf by night was a special
presentation yeah and you don't have to
make these all series you know what I
mean just be like well condense the plot
into a special maybe make it two hours
or something
um yeah I mean
yeah I am for me Marvel that they hit
such a stride round phase three and
phase fours had very much ups and downs
and there's a lot more content coming at
it I think someone posted the the amount
of minutes and days four and compared it
to the all the other phases and it's
there's a ridiculous amount of content
um and it must be a nightmare for one
person to manage I don't know if Kevin
feige should even put like someone in
charge of the Disney Plus shows um
instead of overseeing that himself
because that I mean that was apparently
what one of the main hold ups with blade
was wasn't it that Kevin feige was
stretched too thin
but he's also fixing everything right
now according to the other set of
headlines I keep seeing yeah that's why
everything's delayed all right guys what
about what what is it he's doing a star
war too isn't he Kevin feige yeah yeah
he's doing a Star Wars filmed
how can you two live stream never what's
a live stream first time okay well you
know as much as I love listening to this
podcast between the two of you sometimes
you got to interact with the people in
the live chat you know like that's a big
part of oh there's people there's actual
people listening and I feel like uh once
in a while because you know sometimes
people should send a little bit of bell
our way so know For All Mankind or
Severance huh 900s do you guys watch
um I've never even heard of For All
Mankind I've heard of it it is my
favorite show on TV if you want to talk
about For All Mankind I'll take this
whole thing over right now is it really
are you being sincere right now
For All Mankind is incredible it's an
it's an alternate history show if the
Russians were the first people on the
moon and the Space Race never ended it's
on apple plus it's incredibly acted the
scripts are great like the the actual
science fiction of it fantastic great
show no we won't cover it because nobody
would watch the videos
hey I'm sticking with Andor I'm writing
that thing all the way through
no one's watching it it'll grow
sometimes I'm staying all the way in
there and then uh hey Aaron Bailey I
know that portfolio there yeah great
artist great guy Paul can you do your uh
Robert Baratheon impression for us I got
you busted
Ned me and you used to have a laugh Ned
who used to drink [ __ ] all the holes
it's literally I was having I wasn't
really stressed out that message Paul
about I was in a really stressed out
mood the other day and I was driving
home and listening to him do a a house
of the dragon video and he just broke
out into that breath you know precious
person in the laughter one of the first
real laughs I had that day also never
forget the last that I had that day Paul
it was a great laugh Hardy went to
behold oh my favorite my favorite thing
Paul ever did was I did a peacemaker
video and he he guest starred as the
piss taker yeah
pasta strainer on his head and did the
worst American accent I've ever heard
still makes me laugh when I go back and
watch those Peacemaker videos for fun
let me hear the piss taker
I can't even remember it you know like I
totally forgot until that point but do
an American accent of any kind I just
need to hear that you need to hear my
American accent yeah yeah
different way
with a little bit of a draw drop your
jaw when you talk a lot of Brits become
much Dorial here in the American accent
and I feel like you maintain your sort
of you know your baritone
um so maybe that's why it works so well
we're getting a lot of comments in the
chat about She-Hulk right now okay do
you guys think She-Hulk is gonna it's
not this is the last episode right this
coming week yeah I mean what yeah
apparently I thought it was 10 episodes
I was wrong I planned this whole thing
wrong
do you think it's going to stick the
landing no and that's me being sexist
before you start I just think that
Disney Plus shows have difficulty
sticking the landing what what is a good
Disney plus finale
I'm one of the few that I mean Loki was
good Loki yeah long division Loki
instantly proven wrong was one division
good though
I thought it was like I I didn't get all
the hate for it the problem with one
division was nothing when something like
they did at mystery boxes nothing's ever
going to live up to the handing in your
mind you know what I mean right
not the not the bees and we got a
Phillip Molina is showing some love in
the chat right now good evening okay so
he was the one that's hey Philip we
really appreciated that Twitter post
about us I like being part we like being
like number nine on that thread out of a
million different posts you made that is
nice being acknowledged too if you've
got I mean wait Paul I think you're the
only one who hasn't met Philip in person
yeah I'm not paying money to go meet the
guy
well I live in New York so everybody
should just come to the meeting point
here
oh they've just approached me
apparently
um Spider-Man 4 might be releasing July
12 2024
oh hell yeah it's definitely happening I
thought uh I thought that um Ned didn't
want to return and what's Spider-Man 4
without Ned yeah he's got that deadline
not taken out of context though
wow I'm sure I'll jump right to his
defense when has that ever happened I
don't know let me just throw this out
here
24.
I want every time Ryan to talk for Paul
to start talking at the same time too
basically that's basically my entire how
I feel my entire life every time I make
a video it's like oh he did it
I'll I'll conduct this
um
Ryan
so Ryan what did you want to say
no I just want to hear what everything
Paul has to say Paul what did you want
thanks for delaying that conversation
and wasting time
um so yeah what I was saying was
okay I'm gonna go first we'll just talk
about how I always go first if I don't
so the way I read it was him saying
something like we don't want this to
happen Okay I read it as him meaning
like something bad's gonna happen to
Spider-Man and it's like oh we don't I
don't know if we want to do this because
it's going to completely change the MCU
but it was clearly pushed out of context
to be like
I hate my job I don't want to receive
money just stand around and make a movie
it's exciting like a lot of other things
going on right now yeah
um yeah I mean even for me even if it
was that the latter that he just didn't
want to do it anymore and be like I'm
sure he'd return I like I never really
believe anyone anymore freaking
Wolverine's coming back like I've never
yeah
I bet Patrick Stewart comes back as well
because I was thinking about this the
other day and there's no way that
they'll want to say goodbye to his
version of the character the way that he
goes in Multiverse and Madness you know
I mean or at least that can't be like
the last Professor X thing we ever seen
ideal I'm just getting his neck it's
like that moment is crazy because it
does start off like when he goes like
it's always gonna be the most badass
[ __ ] we've ever seen oh I guess he's
dead he's just right away it was kind of
like that everything
um let's see here hey if if Spider-Man's
coming in July would that be the reason
they pushed everything else just
primary all right
[Laughter]
there it was perfect timing so I think
that's always on board
sorry
this damn delay
I don't think we're live anymore oh
we're not live anymore only we are alive
[Laughter]
it's so late for Paul he's got kids to
tend to and he's wasting his goddamn
time here yeah so what was the original
question will She-Hulk stick The Landing
yeah oh yeah yeah let's go back to that
question 20 minutes later but uh I I
feel like I like She-Hulk more than ever
most of you guys I mean maybe not as
much as John but I feel like I've even
liking it Ryan I feel like you've been
liking it I do no I I have two problems
with the She-Hulk one the fact the VFX
artists have been stretched to their
limits and it's uncanny valley but she's
on screen too I didn't like episode
seven I love everything else about the
show I like that she Hawk was able to go
hey the writers were able to go hey we
know that people are going to troll this
so we're just gonna make those trolls
the actual bad guys in the show and
those same people are still trolling it
in real life that they're just like
either oblivious they're not even
thankful to be included within the show
and I think we're going to see I think
and then I think the show is probably
going to lead right into either
Thunderbolts or right into New World
Order I'm intrigued about the
Intelligentsia because they're a super
villain team in the comics and like uh
claws files said he was a member of the
intelligent like there's a lot of fun
MCU related things they can do to like
really Propel It Forward I think the
videos are going to do well too the
follow-ups Paul
um if you can put your sexism to the
side for just like one minute and how
can you you know objectively look at
Shield
um I think I just think it's been such a
rush like 20 minutes I don't feel like
that's enough to develop
the characters and every time I say
like bring up criticism like it's gen
show and I say something about Daredevil
or someone else like blah blah blah
Abomination they go it's gen show it's
supposed to be She-Hulk show and I'm
like yeah it's I get that but it's also
like at the same time they do they're
spending like 15 minutes an episode on
Immortal man and Donnie Blaze so they
themselves know that it's not gen show
because that's what they're pushing
um and I just feel it's got a really
weird structure to it uh there's I don't
feel that there's that much character
development the worst episode for Ryan
was episode
you thought it was the best one because
it focused on Jim
yeah and I I thought she had an actual
Arc in it um so obviously she was
infatuated with Josh and then at the end
she she grew from that and realized that
she didn't need to do that and came out
refreshed went on an actual Arc whereas
a lot of the other episodes I feel were
very
she even even the first episode I feel
like she starts off in the same place
and ends in the same place
um yeah yeah and it's just like I'm
really good at everything
so okay
that to me isn't an interesting
character well I don't think I don't
think the first episode sorry
I don't think the first episode is
necessarily I'm still really good at
stuff because she's very upfront about
her flaws and how how the world makes
her feel like she's very
she feels small and that's the whole
thing about She-Hulk is Jen is a person
who feels small and She-Hulk allows her
to feel big so the whole show is about
giving herself permission to feel big I
didn't like a few things about episode
seven one I hate what they're doing with
the Abomination too I didn't think it
was funny I thought all the gags with
like the anytime I see like a funny
setting in group therapy I'm always like
okay so I know what these jokes and
beats are going to be and three okay so
Jen gets an arc in the story why is it
every time a woman got an arc like that
it's always got to be because she's
obsessed about a boy yeah yeah true that
was the one thing where I was like come
on like this show up till then had
better things and as far as it being
like Cameo of the week that's what the
com like the best She-Hulk Comics are
that you know from the dance slot and
the Charles Soul Run and everything so
that's why it's everything I wanted it
to be like I said apart from the visual
effects which isn't yeah
this ridiculous
I think we can all agree that the
Daredevil episode was great yeah I
haven't really seen in that getting any
hate at all to be honest except for he
did the Walk of Shame
she had a great Arc in that episode dude
congrats on going viral with that
sarcastic tweet oh yeah we started
recording yeah
listen guys we're about Midway through
the stream and this is just uh an
impromptu feeling I'm having right now
okay yeah I feel like we should you know
kind of explain the meaning behind our
shirts okay in fact I might have your
emotions and reasoning written down here
but I'll let you guys actually do the
explaining here I love how these are
written from first person point of view
this is a test you have to guess what
these say verbatim otherwise your stores
will be closed and we will automatically
win this doesn't sound like
this nah I kind of want to read it just
like hey here's what Paul told me
all right hey it's me Paulie get
yourself you should you look dapper in
it I always imagine you as Andrew Dice
Clay when I think so John how'd you come
up with the citizen Kang shirt why don't
you read what you wrote down because you
didn't want to mess this up I came up
with it John myself I had no input from
Greg it's not mostly all his design with
Kang being guys listen with Kang being
the next big Baddie of the MC Ryan
you're going to want to hear this Ryan
where the [ __ ] did you go why are you I
see how it is
wow okay I'm gonna take this personally
right Arie all right I was in the back I
could hear you it's all good you better
be finding me like an obscure tape or
something like that with Kang being the
next big Baddie of the MCU you know we
knew it was just common knowledge
between us that we had to come up with
design with him in mind wow and uh hey I
mean you know we both love Cinema and
Greg you're going off script
we have to read a verse the idea how did
fans impact it what elements do you like
most about it and one of the sides from
your collection are your favorites
that's how I came up with this shirt I
asked myself all those questions and
thought I have no favorites I'll have to
create one that I can call my own and it
was this it was this it wasn't uh it
wasn't the zero zero one vechna shirt
and it wasn't uh us as Steve and Dustin
and it wasn't the rated R logo shirt
that's not my favorite either it wasn't
uh the nipple chills shirt it wasn't the
tickets shirt that's I think over there
it wasn't the shirt that I can't show on
screen because it's not allowed to sell
it so uh it's not this beanie either I
don't love this beanie as much as I love
this king shirt what I remember about
creating the citizen king shirt was
there was a lot of debate about whether
or not we should have have his window
have have the window of the Multiverse
that was the biggest debate that we kept
having back and forth and then
ultimately he came up with a bunch of
reasons and if if I'm being totally
honest it looks like a bunch of sperms
circling each other by the end of it
when I actually looked it up I was like
maybe this is what they were thinking
but just didn't want to tell me
but I love it oh my god look who's in
the live stream oh yeah
this is a perfect transition here man
perfect Transit because Ryan hey
look why don't you tell us what's up I'm
gonna just throw away the script here
and why don't you tell us no way about
what inspired you to come up with and
not the B shirt and we got to get back
to the chat and then well actually I I
didn't come up with the idea for the
shirt Doug did
so unfortunately I can't actually he's
really excited right now because it's
his lunch time so I I don't remember
much about it maybe Doug will tell you
I'll be right I'll be right back I'm
just going to step over here for a
second so Doug can tell you about it
yeah I came up with the idea for the not
the B shirt because you know we're all
the time talking about my sister in the
in the videos and stuff and I just in a
rear was cutting out the booze and that
was actually our editor Harriet linger
in right here came up with that and we
thought you know that's just like a
screen Crush joke that we do that's a
lot of fun and everybody enjoys it so we
uh you know we put that in the shirt you
know it ever did it with the text and
everybody sees it they know what it is
and we're just we're just happy to have
a good time guys you know
oh very insightful wow did he do a good
job I was in the other room I didn't
hear any of that how do you do the way
you made Doug's mouth move up and down
with your hand up his ass the whole time
was really impressive stuff I don't know
how you I don't know what you're talking
about guys he I couldn't even tell your
lips were moving while his work that was
really really great he's his own man
say Paul
a birthday idea
years ago I was watching back or Saul
um
it was covering back or saw recently and
obviously the poster of it is really
good so I thought you know change that a
better call Paul She hulks a little show
better call swords a little show tied in
you need a spoiler need huge movie twist
better call Paul what else does it say
just keep pulling your shirt up yeah we
can't see your belly button and the
whole time dead the whole time on that
that's one of the spoilers the busiest
it was a dream not the last spoiler oh I
spoiled all the moves
what does it say on the bottom uh like
comment subscribe guys I'm not even
I'm not even being a wise ass here
that's an awesome shirt like I separate
from like you know being friends with
you and and enjoying your channel I
would totally buy that shirt because
those are you know it's the Homer it's
the home it's the first time I've ever
seen it because the first thing I do
every morning is refresh your merch page
or you could send me or you could send
me one and I could just like wear it
every now and then on the channel and
then you'd make money from it but like
you know whatever I think it's a really
cool shirt and the Penguin too because
the Kang one's great because you look at
it and if you know it you know it if you
don't you don't it's okay Ryan yeah I
could see that you thought we were
feeling left out of your compliment game
here but it's okay you don't have to
just try to
stuff go to shopzeroedition.com it
really is a great way to support the
channel as much as we can be sarcastic
[ __ ] it really is and I am proud of
our designs I really am on a sincere
note I'm proud of all of our designs and
a lot I remember when you guys first
launched your designs I remember uh
beating the champion like holy [ __ ] you
guys actually came up with some great
like your theory time shirt Ryan genius
yeah I mean not series time that's Paul
the [ __ ] uh Star Wars one yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] was the Star Wars one that
was the one I was like yeah boom
or whatever
Theory times like one of my favorite
things Paul does in his videos makes me
laugh every time and the boys the boys
official Twitter account shouted that
out too I really like history man Paul's
too famous
um hey we got some more money I should
um hold on right hold the thought please
we got more uh it's a I love it's about
Scott about I love phase four and I
prefer what's been going on with the the
laser useful now spreads things out now
should be more wbn like special
presentations
I think werewolf by night is one of the
best things I've seen it twice now and
it's personal I think it just hits my
personal like taste buds because I I
love the the universal monster like era
and everything that they Encompass and I
thought they really captured this Beyond
just the aesthetic I thought they really
captured thematically what they really
do with their monsters that's not about
like what made what made them impactful
was not the fact that they were
necessarily terrifying but the internal
fears within them that sort of become
these physical manifestations and I
thought that's what they captured so
well by giving such pathos to to the
monsters within their man thing and and
the Werewolf of course but just my
personal pretentious opinion
um yeah yeah I think the special
presentations as well it just it's
probably less pressure for the the
creatives and because they're not having
to fit stuff they they have a story they
want to tell no one's going it needs to
be six episodes so drag it out they're
not having to structure it to a TV show
where it's got a cliffhanger every week
so people come back for the next one
it's not a movie so there's not like
you know they've got to please investors
and all the pressure that comes with a
film release and I think that's probably
the way that marble should be going with
this stuff have the big tentpole movies
and then the you know the more obscure
characters get them get them a special
presentation Michael giacchino killed it
as well directed and scored it really
did he did his best he works so much as
well like pretty much scores every film
at the moment now he's got time off just
throwing it out there if you guys want
to get a rejack nation jacket I've been
wearing this and I never show it a
rejack nation Jack everyone off camera
so much and I never show the back of it
um yeah I thought he absolutely killed
it and apparently has time off now and I
I feel like they're gonna you know give
him a property and then yeah he's gonna
make a film for the MCU then it's gonna
suck then everyone's gonna be like he's
ruining the MCU and he should never work
again in Hollywood because you know
that's the way we are with directors and
I mean he scored the Batman throw a
living Thunder Spider-Man no way home
that's all within the last year
heavy misinformation
did Jurassic world Dominion as well when
is this guy going to stop
are you reading his IMDb right now yeah
he's not on a break right now how does
he do all this work he is like actually
on a break
um thank you to all who have bought
shirts from shopzeroedition.com by the
way because uh I always feel proud when
people send in photos of it dude do
people send in photos if they actually
buy your shirts do they do they show you
like hey I'm like yeah it's pretty cool
I actually it's really cool you feel
like Blissful about it whenever I see
that so thank you guys for the support
especially when YouTube shuts down
monetization for a full day it really
does help out when you guys buy a team
for literally no reason yeah that was
that was really stressful looking at the
analytics the next day guys you can't
[ __ ] believe me it was a bus and we
have no way to track the ads uh Connor
Belmont says did anyone else get nipple
shields thank you thank you where's that
nipple chill sure we also got a nipple
chill shirt here somewhere
um Gia which which if that was one of
the questions there you go if that was
one of the questions on um this this
little cheat sheet we have here
the history behind nipple chills is for
some reason my nipples do just get like
really inflated for some reason whenever
I get excited over something that's the
way it goes to you
um but yeah I definitely uh I I got so
excited I I had actually a hard time
paying attention when Matt Murdoch first
showed up because I was so captivated by
the fact that he was actually there and
I was like I should actually be trying
to absorb what Matt Murdoch's trying to
say right now and do you guys agree with
any of the sentiments at all that Matt
Murdock I love how we thought we were
going to talk about House of the Dragon
versus rings of power that we haven't
touched one bit but that conversation is
pretty simple it's just one has way more
character and the other one has a lot of
money but
um do you guys share any of the
sentiment at all about Nat Murdock
um because some people were feeling that
they they made them a little too funny
for it and I personally I enjoyed it I
thought it fit with with the tone of the
show I mean he was never gonna come in
and be like Kingpin murdered my father I
must get revenge and in Los Angeles
I'm defending a woman who's had a house
burned down in her pets were killed by
Mobsters you know what I mean it was
never going to be that in She-Hulk so
I mean I thought it was I thought it was
fine for the tone of the show I thought
it was pretty good I enjoyed it
Ryan are you paying attention to the
live stream
I am um I
in the clip so the problem was they
showed that clip first where he goes my
ass remains unwoofed which did seem
pretty goofy because it was out of
context the thing you have to like if
you read the comics everybody watches
the Netflix show and they've never read
a comic and they go oh that's what Matt
he's not always like that obviously when
we talk about Matt Murdock we usually
talk about the Frank Miller stuff uh
where it was more dark and gritty but
even those Comics would have their
lighthearted moments because Matt
Murdock is a human being who enjoys you
know things that human beings enjoy so
there's also one of the best recent runs
of Daredevil is with Mark Wade where he
lives in LA and he's just happy like his
Pub his identity is public and it's just
Matt Murdock actually enjoying his life
for once so yeah and plus it's on
She-Hulk like Paul said so you couldn't
have him come in and you know uh my
ex-girlfriend's a heroin addict and she
sold my identity the Kingpin like that
stuff's coming this was a lighthearted
thing just like in the She-Hulk Comics
the characters show up and they do funny
lighthearted things and then they go off
on their own and Spider-Man's sad
because Dr Octopus stole his body and
stuff like that
oh yeah no you make solid solid points
and since we're still on the topic of
She-Hulk worst episode of the whole
stream is
the finale this week support the channel
but buying some shirts and then if uh
whoever wins the whoever gets sells the
most shirts in the next 24 hours
um gets to keep Doug is that what we
agreed on that uh we wanna we'll get to
keep Doug and Doug will belong to an
actual loving family and not this
potentially monetization game that
Ryan's playing here with his puppy it's
not actionable love
around the house we're clearly in a
store heavy spoilers
worst episode is wedding episode but the
whole show has been the most comic
accurate type show and what it was
advertised to be a 24-minute sitcom sure
I still feel like there's some
structural issues for sure
I don't know if it necessarily does fit
the structure of a sitcom completely
I'll tell you why
if you buy [ __ ] no so
what is one of the big things in sitcoms
you've got your your cast of characters
you've got your you know your Joey's
your channel is your monikers Rachel's
there
yeah a big appeal about a a sitcom is
the supporting characters and the the
side characters and stuff
and She-Hulk is just introducing and
adding new ones every week and also a
sitcom it's a situation comedy that's
meant to be you know a location like
Central Perk or the apartment
um or Seinfeld where wherever that is or
Frasier with the I think they all have
their bases yeah cheers is a bar you
know what I mean you're thinking of a
live camera audience sitcom yeah yeah I
that's the only kind of cheap I think
I've never finished yet She-Hulk they're
changing the locations every single
episode and they're adding characters
every single episode so it's not 100
fitting the mold of a sitcom either
what would you kind of other than if you
remove the musical element from Crazy
Ex-Girlfriend what would you categorize
that as because that's more akin to the
type of genre that I find She-Hulk to be
where I don't even know what that is You
Haven't Seen Crazy Ex-Girlfriend it's
the greatest show of all time it's way
better
yeah yeah
um I mean yeah it's not a sitcom because
it's it's too long to be a sitcom like
every episode is 40 minutes right well
there's like a single camera I get what
John's arguing about like single camera
sitcom but even those use like
repetitive locations it does seem like
it changes the even even if it's
following okay here's where I could meet
Paul like pretty much halfway on it even
though I've really been enjoying the
show I would also say that even if it is
a sitcom it's not a great sitcom I
wouldn't call it like a solid sitcom
though like if I was like watch this
sitcom I'm sure people might be like
this isn't that great of a an actual
sitcom you know
I would say one division was a better
sitcom because it was all confined to
the house
where it's had its jokes in you know the
the bit about when it was living
literally in a recreated system yeah
when Vision was
stuck chewing the chewing gum we're
gonna laugh with that
um so that was in a situation it had all
the characters were recurring characters
they weren't really introducing new
characters every episode
and it was based on sitcoms you see what
I'm saying I would say that was more of
a sitcom yeah I I I still said the pro
you're looking at sitcoms with two
narrow of a definition of it I think
because like sitcom is short for
situational comedy but that's because at
the time when they came out the other
comedy shows were like said Caesar in
your show of shows Milton Burrough were
like variety shows so the point of a
sitcom is we're gonna put Lucy and her
husband in a house and it's it's about
this lady she lives she's at home all
the time and her husband's a TV producer
and obviously the reason it was stuck to
one place is because it's cheaper and
the reason they have the same cast every
week is because it's cheaper but there
are sitcoms that have fit the mode of
she-hawk the one that comes to mind the
most is Murphy Brown which did have an
office that Murphy worked in it also had
her home just like those the two primary
locations in She-Hulk but it also had
like kind of a revolving door of guest
stars either people like politicians or
people who were they were doing news
stories about that week or Murphy every
week had a different secretary that
wouldn't work out that would always
cause her headaches and problems and she
had a lot of the same problems that
Jennifer is going through and like just
being professional woman facing sexism
being the best of what she does and
having to work twice as hard all that
kind of stuff
well so I think I think the main really
quick I'm going to wrap up that point
there but look look for you right
duck that's for Doug
um
you know what it was I there was when it
clicked for me about what I mean by the
sitcom bit is and on episode seven
Paul's favorite episode my least
favorite episode Ryan's least favorite
episode
um when she got to the point where she
was you know going through the Arc in
the group therapy moment I didn't feel
like that monologue was necessarily
earned and I didn't really feel much for
it like I was like I I get why it's here
but the focus of her journey is not
really
it feels kind of clunky on the way there
like it's all technically there on paper
but there's something about the
emotional feels for her journey and I
still feel like even for sitcoms you do
latch into that really well granted
that's just my opinion I know a lot of
people really felt for that moment I
just didn't and then you know yeah I
think another problem with it is that
it's trying to be a sitcom but it's also
got to have this overarching story of
the MCU and so like the episode one is
not a sitcom episode at all that is just
her an origin story episode yeah and
then you've got teasers of the
intelligencia
and teasers of Daredevil and Todd
constantly popping up like what's going
on with him The Wrecking Crew stabbing
her it can be like the boss so you've
got this overarching thing as well which
is I I feel that someone stepped in at
that point during the writing process
and was like it's an MCU thing we've got
to have gotta have a big finale and big
payoff whereas most sitcoms don't really
have a big finale you know I mean they
just have like people sitting around in
a coffee shop look we gotta get this out
of the way really fast
all right Paul I want I know Paul's
answer Ryan
brings a Power House of the Dragon
they they have the opposite problems I
think House of the Dragons got to pump
the brakes a little bit because the time
jumps are way too jarring for me whereas
the rings of power honestly I think it's
a better looking show but they're really
teasing out certain Mysteries that at
this point I think are kind of easy to
identify and I hate when shows try to
base their whole narrative around a
mystery it's kind of it's good for
business for us to like always tease out
the mystery but then you get something
like Hawkeye which is not we're talking
about but Hawkeye like just should have
revealed the Kingpin was the villain
like from the start
um which one am I enjoying more
wait say what Paul I'm sorry Hawkeye
even had a scene where they were gonna
reveal it in episode three that it was
Kingpin because they had that scene with
um and then obviously they saw the
success of One Division were like no
could have gotta keep people guessing
it's Mephisto
wait a minute when it was pretty obvious
who it would be
um I like House of the Dragon more than
rings of power
I don't know who Sauron is do you guys
know who saw Ron is did you figure it
out already I guess it's hard right give
me Hall brand
here maybe he forgot and now he's gonna
remember yeah
you're like 100 sold it's all right yeah
well I mean even the structure of the
way
wrote off together at the end of the
last episode didn't they so I think
they're going to get somewhere and be
like sauron's down here I know I know it
and then
she'll find out that uh
it's Hal brand it feels they're together
they're together in this situation like
Paul's definitely having a hard time
with rings of power his last uh yeah
made me crack up in those last 10
minutes
from it so much of your breakdown as you
clarifying like look I don't want to
slag on the show too much but but here's
why this show should go [ __ ] stuff
here's why I don't really like this
running all my bridges with Amazon
um yeah I just feel the pacings off
completely
um yeah I just don't there's so many
scenes I think you've done this seven
times in the show already you can cut
this scene no I mean it is going on
about it will be about nine hours once
the entire thing finishes because
though every time I say this it's like
well no it's been eight hours so far
it's like no because most of the
episodes are about an hour and 10
minutes so we add all that up it it's
longer than the the Lord of the Rings
trilogy at this point and nothing's
really happened well my favorite my
favorite I don't disagree
my favorite negative comment that Paul
gets when he doesn't like something and
rings of power is like well I don't know
man I like slow character different
stories which is fine
you can see why someone has a criticism
of that yeah
or that Paul's just racist we need
character beats I also have a character
driven series
I get I totally get the character beats
that each character has that's the thing
it's just I don't need to be told 700
times the same thing I mean the amount
of times that Galadriel was like Sauron
is I'm telling you sauron's coming in at
characters like oh I don't believe you
don't don't really think he is and then
eventually they were like you know what
maybe he is coming we we should go on
this Quest and then the next episode it
would be Galadriel again telling people
Sauron was coming
what get that out the way just cut that
I feel like the weakest part of rings of
power is often the thing that mattered
most which is the lining of the
characters like that that is the main
thing they should have nailed because I
I like a few of those characters a lot
but there's also like a lot of
characters and oftentimes there's
something about the placement of the
scenes that I'm usually like cool fun
yeah like I feel like Ryan you can
really like dive into the lore a lot and
and you really eat that up and I feel
like that can
that can add more points for you than
someone like John and I who are not as
lore and heavy knowledgeable about it
already so I feel like that can actually
work towards your day same thing for
like people who are hardcore Tolkien
fans who will come in and be like yeah I
mean this is like tolkien's writings and
whatever that and for me I because I
don't have as much of that preconceived
investment
that doesn't matter to me as much as
much as the emotional investment of the
journey so I think they also made errors
in the way that they structured the
villains like
if you are a newcomer to this show which
I mean most people will have seen Lord
of the Rings
um but things like morgoth it unless you
read the the original work the name
morgoth you're just gonna be like I
don't know who that is and then all of a
sudden he's gone and it's like oh no
it's Sauron they don't even really
explain what happens with morgoth um and
now you're you're suddenly focusing on
Sauron and then it's the same with the
balrog as well and jiren drops the leaf
in and it lands and then the balrog
starts to form if you've got no idea
what the balrog is you don't understand
why that happens you know I mean there's
not really
there was never a point in the show
where it was like oh we need to stop
digging because something lurks I mean
during for some reason I was like we
can't keep taking it yeah exactly but he
didn't know there was a power rug down
there because he wouldn't have thrown
the leaf in there
there's not a reason for it
um and to me the the dwarves originally
they were so greedy that they just kept
digging and digging and I feel that
jiren should have been like yeah go full
steam ahead dig more get all the
material you can
um and instead he's like no we we don't
like to dig too deep but why just don't
do it
reveal didn't work
okay for the reason you said I agree
completely because
it's a member it's a member Barry
totally we are just now watching
episodes of heavy spoilers
was so funny to me about that balrog
moment since you guys are like doesn't
work doesn't work doesn't work like we
were like we know what it is
there we know all that but
knowing the books I'm like no it didn't
work it didn't work to me if I could go
back actually the Bull rock did not
appear until the end of the second age
so clearly the timeline here is uh
it's a real about to go back to Jeff
Bezos bizo in the house and go look mate
that Montage at the start of episode one
that tells about the death of
galadriel's brother
make that the whole first season make
that the first season you know make it a
Game of Thrones season one where Ned
Stark gets executed at the the end of
episode nine have finrod's death be this
big thing that happens
and then you know collateral say oh crap
this big character he was such a strong
influence in my life gotta go out and
kill Sauron now where is the motivation
for doing it we don't get to know finrod
that well so we're not that invested and
we know that sauron's gonna come down
the line anyway so whatever the plan is
it's not gonna pan out it feels like the
action movie Trope and I feel like what
works against a lot of Lord of the Rings
media posts the actual Lord of the Rings
trilogy of movies is I feel like people
rest too heavily on the stoicism and
it's just like get all these characters
were like I'm really stoic and I'm
Purpose Driven and that's all my
dialogue is going to reflect in any
other character is going to have to come
from the actor and maybe a directing
choice and that's it except for Duran
and elrond and I feel like that dog The
Hobbit movies and that dog's this pretty
heavily too even Kelli Bowen's death we
should have seen that you know I mean
but he's not dead he's not he's not dead
he's Pro he's not dead obviously yeah
but we should have seen the scene that
she talks about so we could get invested
in like oh my god galadriela brother she
was with him for five episodes and he
got killed Keller born a husband she
thinks he's dead oh my God I can't
believe it that would have got me more
invested because you know the house of
the Dragon
they're getting you invested in the
characters like you know are gonna die
spoiler alert but you're seeing that
journey and I know they have big time
jumps and stuff but the important points
are Hit Upon and we see them whereas
rings of fire is like the important
stuff happened in that Montage back in
episode one and now we're just wandering
around and telling people
you need to get ready for Sauron I don't
believe you though come on out get ready
for sound but don't believe you we'll
get ready for him and that's like an
entire episode so like two two hobbit
movies have already had the saurons
coming plot line yeah and uh and that's
how I do feel like morgoth especially as
an audience member when you're like we
know sauron's coming yeah
Mo goth was even power is way better
than Hobbit though
yeah I'll meet you there yeah so maybe
five armies yeah
um all right uh let's go Christina B
what's the next MCU special presentation
you'd like to see thanks for the Super
Chat there thank you
the next MCU Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special
one I know it is
[Laughter]
yeah I'll take the low hanging fruit
please
or I guess the fun way to put this is
what would be the one we'd like there to
be a special captain
oh
one of the Illuminati members
I want a Easter special where Iron Man
comes back from the dead yeah yeah it
resurrects from the cave yeah and the
two movements
Tony was Jesus this whole time he walks
out in a nanotech shroud yeah it's gonna
be good they could even do a
uh in humans one you know fixed in
humans with it just a special yeah
yeah get black ball back baby I want my
man spider special and end the special
with Black Lagoon where you going Black
Bolt
and you obviously can't talk uh but he
types in his phone in his notes just
going to meet with my friends at the
Illuminati there's another doctor
strange just appeared in our universe
and then he stares at the camera
everyone's like oh no don't go Black
Bolt oh let's connect yeah
I love tying no answer mount
um
well you know speaking of all these like
shows that are creative
I just have a sincere thought about the
shirts guys of why I'm proud of what we
do okay because
we we do so much commentary on other
people's creativity
that's a nice time we get to put our own
creativity on there for example how did
you come up with better call Paul
of our other shirts
um if you look at the shirts there is a
lot of I I think it's fun when you do
get involved with the actual designs of
these things and it's something that we
get to put our names on for and that is
something that has a creative
resemblance of something from our minds
versus you know just us because it takes
creativity to put the videos together
don't do me wrong
um but this is something that's a little
bit more finite and now Ryan Ryan has
novels too you should buy his novels
don't you have novels
uh I wrote one yeah it's not published
though no it's not very good yet still
still in the revision phase read it on
the live stream and I'm pissed off I am
going to the backstory audiobook live so
maybe I think you're ruining the
franchise
no we should buy it hey
for my favorite internet hotties you
Chumps that's how she sounds too when
she says it
you chump yeah Chumps I appreciate it we
love you pretty Nikki Paul had zero
reaction to that you see that for my
internet hot easy Chumps and Paul's just
sat there
Stone Cold like an internet hot he would
I appreciate it
I've heard this many times that's really
nice
thank you for saying that
no she massively supports my channel I
really appreciate it
uh yes
oh yeah no don't worry uh it's gonna go
right to our base thanks Nikki much love
um Joshua Mendes
wow that's a big Super Chat thank you
spent way too much time on this LOL
Rotten Tomato audience score averages
not including She-Hulk and werewolf by
night oh this is cool oh a lot phase one
average 79 phase two average 84 phase
three 83 phase 488 but isn't there more
in phase four than the other faces
so technically the average should be
lower though if there's more yeah
because at the same time it was Rotten
Tomatoes
sorry Ryan you go
no it's okay no Greg I'm sorry I stepped
over you go ahead no Ryan please I I
feel like you should be the one to speak
right now right the thing the thing that
I care the least about no offense to
Josh is I I audience scores on Rotten
Tomatoes I don't care because they we've
seen they can be review bombed for
different reasons I back in the day
Rotten Tomatoes was cool because if you
like to read movie reviews from
professional film critics who studied
film for a living that's how I learned
about film criticism was by reading them
if you wanted to find film critics you
would go on Rotten Tomatoes and you
would look at different reviews and then
you'd go to those websites from those
critics and it would it was a way to
like broaden your horizons now since
they were bought who owns them as a WB
who owns them no yep yeah they've just
become such a marketing tool and that's
all they're for so like every single
thing in film has to be well it was a
rotten refresh because of 59 of
arbitrarily pulled Critics on the
internet don't you know don't like the
whole event it's rotten we can't watch
it guys and the audience score makes
that even worse I know it's there so
it's an interactive thing so people fans
feel they're involved but fans show
their involvement by buying tickets and
watching things I don't really I've
never read an audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes now I don't think I might go on
other websites for it or social media
but not a Rotten Tomatoes
yeah it's scores like average ones in
general are very strange because like we
as critics actively seek out things that
are going to interest us you know what I
mean like I'm not there'll be some
movies I'm not gonna review so it the
the critic score is going to be skewed
anyway because a lot of people are going
to just seek out things that they
actually want to see and review that
sure and so that's probably going to be
more positive
um audience they've got a weird thing
with Rotten Tomatoes where they'll give
a score to a season before it's even
finished it'll be like
House of the Dragon 90 percent
it's like I I agree that's great but you
don't know that yet like they could have
a season eight Game of Thrones thing
um so just don't see the point in
scores yeah because I release the press
screeners and then they review a couple
of episodes
yeah Studios can control how much you
see as well to get that score
um and there's been a number of them
where they'll give you two episodes for
one thing and then the next thing will
come along and be like no we'll give you
four episodes and they can very much
control how much of a positive impact
that it has on you because you see where
certain arcs go
um or you don't
so I just think the whole system's a bit
pointless I'm a bit cynical over it and
there's so many things that I've got bad
scores that I've really enjoyed and so
many things that I've got great scores
that I've watched and thought
I think more often than not if something
has like 90 on Rotten Tomatoes that's
just come out I'll go watch it and be
like
yeah it was okay it wasn't amazing
it's just easy to forget that it's it's
also like the aggregate is of like if
it's a three out of five that's
technically positive or if it's less
than three it's technically negative so
the score itself oversimplifies what all
the reviews are trying to say yeah as
they've been oversimplified by their
number of scores anyway so yeah
the audience score is also done this
horrible thing where it invests too much
of the audience into the work itself and
into the film criticism because for some
reason now we have everything in America
has to be political so Lord rings of
power shows character posters and people
go oh the loudest people go you can't
have a black L if you can't have a black
dwarf so then everyone who's not
horrible feels like we have to stand up
and defend rings of power simply be for
that reason against this when you may
you know hate rings of power and not
care at all that there's minority
characters in it so that's another thing
the audience score has done it's just
given too loud of a voice to the most
horrible people who are often the people
who the only people who actually want to
exercise that voice and it forces it
makes everybody else feel like they have
to defend something they don't even
really care about like a lot of people
who maybe Rose to the defensive rings of
power never even saw Lord of the Rings
but they're just kind of funneled into
that through social media I personally
love rings of power I don't really don't
understand any of that hate around it
but that's a different show well
especially with the marketing lead I
think I think more than when the actual
product comes out a lot of the time it's
the lead up to the release when that
when the rage clicks really come through
even on especially on YouTube like it's
really easy to capitalize on that type
of thought process
for something like rings of power there
are channels that I think all of us can
think about right now that come to mind
that you know like you know those
thumbnails you know exactly what they're
talking about you know they're going to
talk about virtue signaling and whatever
without having seen a single thing or
taken in the context of it but it's
really easy to so then so then when
those videos are getting pushed and that
becomes a social media comp it's
something yeah that does become sort of
this lens that some people start to view
it through yeah like I got into an
argument I mean I rarely reply to
comments because they they tend to
evolve into if they're positive I'll
I'll try and reply but sometimes I'll
reply to negative ones and this guy the
other day was eventually got to the
point where he was like I have this
sneaking suspicion that you guys just
hate rings of power because you're white
people that
don't like diversity in the show and I'm
like I've never in none of my reviews
have I mentioned anyone's skin color or
that their race or anything
um and it's just getting to the point
where it's just an automatic response of
you're criticizing this thing so you
must be a racist or you must hate women
I say well have I mentioned that in any
of the things I've said it's like no but
that's the reason you're doing it
if I could just the most enjoyable
characters
I I just have an appeal for anybody out
there if you if you do feel like you
have like a a thought or something about
a show instead of like channeling that
in a hateful way you should channel that
love or hate of something by buying
shirts like we have this original
trilogy t-shirt which is a really nice
way to express how you feel without
being mean than not the B shirt Citizen
Kane better call all of these are
healthy ways to deal with your rage to
buy these shirts on shopzeroedition.com
it's very true Paul only works when he
has to so you know you should only favor
you know Ryan and Greg and John today
because let's just face it does Paul
really wear that when uh he's not
required to to learn
no okay I'm sorry I take it back I'm
sorry
to doubt your integrity all right sorry
I do feel the culture was kind of
dominating a lot of the conversation and
it really that I watched Lord of the
Rings uh the fellowship the other day
and Erwin you know when she gets Frodo
and she rides in all the Naz Gula
chasing after her and then she gets to
the water and she takes them all out
takes them all out I was thinking if
this was released today yeah if this was
released today the Mary Sue complaints
would be crazy I mean claim him Harwin
and eowin
in return of the Kingdom well um
but also anyone says that in the book
but Arvin I don't think is the person
who beats Frank brings Frodo into
Rivendell in the book so that's where
they'd be like hey when they'd be like
oh well that's in the book that's Canon
but anything else [ __ ] then to me
yeah
I honestly don't care about the culture
War I really don't care
um and I I do kind of get
frustrated with the conversation around
it sometimes when it's like this is woke
and I might
it's not like I don't care a lot of
people don't even know what it means
yeah it just means anything at the
moment they're not even using the word
woke correctly
did you see it used on Fox News and I'm
like that's you sound stupid when you
say that that's not even what that means
you're not using it right whatever it
must be woke
instead of woke thing should I be should
I be mad should I be mad I don't even
know if it's woke yeah and some of the
arguments are so stupid like She-Hulk
took down Hulk she she stopped his car
don't care
but that also touches on some of the fun
things about fandom like right there
it's coming from a sexist place but I've
had like in in my in my Angry youth I've
had screaming arguments with people
about how Darth Vader would absolutely
decimate data in a fight and it wouldn't
even be closed and I won this argument
and then my friend said yeah the data
would be in the chess so you know like
we love those conversations and those
arguments but I just don't care about
winning those arguments I would rather
just do something else and that's kind
of when I switch off
um yeah
all right guys listen we um I just I
wanted to say into the chat right now
are you guys enjoying this stream
um I do it again I've texted a few
people we got a few super chats to go
through Paul I know it's like midnight
for you you got some kids crying and
screaming in the background your wife's
yelling at you to come upstairs and I
know that this is the best distraction
for you but you should probably be
responsible at some point tonight so
we'll get you back there in a bit but we
got some comments to go through I texted
some people they think we're doing a
good job if you guys think we're doing a
good job in this stream one thing you
can do leave a like second thing
support it's a shopzeroedition.com buy
any one shirt I don't even care if you
buy ours
even though I mean it's preferable it's
the best way to support the channel and
you get something back
yeah and please express your love for
the the channel I don't know about you
guys there's been plenty of times with
the vechner shirt that we have and the
in this shirt or I've had people come up
to me and be like that's a cool shirt
and I'm just like thanks
and I don't even like try to promote it
or be like well you can get it
I have no idea just wear a lanyard with
the QR code on it so that you can see it
I hope you can actually like it here
just scan that with your friends
dude print QR codes on the sleeves of
each one so if anyone asks you can just
go scan this yeah I've never uh I have
no idea how to just be like hey why
don't you go and buy it
um but I we do get compliments a lot
that's that's a good way to start just
go hey buy the shirt all right all right
and we'll do this we'll have to go
through these a little bit quickly but
thank you to all who have been here in
this chat so far and thank you to all
who have support us for
shopzeroedition.com
um because we got more coming up every
month we got and and this next one John
came up with our shirt oh no John came
up with it oh no I turned it down but
then uh I didn't agree with it but the
higher ups of Zero edition they
there's deals going on in Puerto Rico
right now with tax purposes and they
thought John's worked better over there
yellow ghost hey guys had nipple chills
when Deadpool 3 was announced for my
birthday in 2024. awesome happy early
birthday my nipples now feel like Uncle
Ben in the end I love how the nipple
chills thing took off my nipples now
feel like Uncle Ben in the MCU Dead and
Gone cheers I think delays are can be
good because it always gives them more
time to prep that's something that I've
heard a lot about with pan in the
pandemic discussions with some of the
greatest things like even for Better
Call Saul uh Vince Gilligan and Peter
goldber saying that one of the best
weirdest best things that happened to
them was the fact that the pandemic
occurred so allowed them more time to
write the final season and if they
didn't have the pandemic they probably
wouldn't have been able to deliver such
a great season so coven was a great
thing all around yeah great like the
writer strike for Breaking Bad season
too
okay we're gonna kill Jesse off the
rider strike cap and then they had more
time to plan out season three or season
two what I thought it was gonna die in
season one I thought season one was when
they were gonna go online the writer
strike gave them time to plan out season
two which is why season two had the
airplane and everything was really the
ABQ down uh thing that they did is that
Andres galagost comment in the chat uh
Jamie elano uh Michael giacchino or as I
call Micro gynecologists should get
Blade in my opinion I would
I guess I'd be down for that I I don't
know I feel like you kind of put them in
a box at that point and I feel like you
don't really want to box Michael Chino
in because you you some of these bigger
movies as much as we it seems like there
has to be kind of a middle ground here
where a director can do what they really
want to do but also need a little bit of
guidance in order because sometimes you
can give too much rain and some of these
movies I don't know it seems like such
an up and down experience at the MCU as
of late but I personally would while
Michael giaccino kind of stay more in
the terrain of I want to do this because
I want to do it versus you did a good
job in werewolf by night now you want to
do this modern vampire action thriller I
I don't he could do a good job but it's
not the one I personally would want if
anything I want to see him focus on a
werewolf by night too more than I would
want him to see do play but who do you I
mean do you guys have any any picks for
you know I think like someone one of the
John Wick directors would be a good
blade pick for one of these films
to direct it Steve McQueen yeah that's
gonna be just a story about like intense
blood addiction I mean
I I don't want him to write it but I'd
love to see Robert Rodriguez direct it
you know we've seen him do vampire
action before
um if you're gonna just wish list out of
The Ether than Quentin Tarantino is
obviously the best person to direct any
Marvel ever especially one like blade
but you know I guess I just have From
Dusk Till Dawn in my head
do you have a pic Paul
no I want Spike Lee's blade way to
participate in the live stream today
Paul I really appreciate I was gonna say
Jordan peel but he wouldn't do it he's
kind of above it yeah well obviously
Jordan peel is
you never know though I mean Sam Raimi
I mean that is the directors at the
moment where he sells original ideas on
his name you know what I mean
so they could if they were
hypothetically to hand him the reins he
could probably make the project he wants
to make
yeah theoretically right it was a Marvel
presentations dude a special
presentation then yeah I don't know
about a full future film but I feel like
a Jordan P would have more pull over
that whole project than the guy who just
lost yeah you know if anything I just
wanted to he'll do a vampire movie that
would be more than blade I would just
like do a vampire movie let Wesley
Snipes direct it vampire Hunter baby
it's got about phase four hits hard for
me because I have way more relatable
character thank you for this multiple
super chats here I have way more
relatable characters than this phase and
the relatable theme of grief depression
and Trauma got me I thought that worked
strongest in I mean I thought Moon
Knight had a really great episode uh Arc
with that but uh I feel like Wanda
Vision just really knocked it out of the
park in that department that's true yeah
Noe home had had good moments too
obviously the death event May and it was
quite a big thing I do kind of wish
they'd focused on the five years in
between the snap and the blip because I
feel like we've got a video coming out
about that right now yeah yeah there's
some uh well mine's about to drop in 10
minutes
um but there's just so much stuff that's
unexplored in that
um
that we don't hear about
uh it just I mean Hawkeye kind of
touched upon it one division did uh with
Hayworth saying they were dark times and
that's really all we've had and I would
love to see something exploring that get
a special presentation of
like uh agents of Sword during that time
or something I want to see like one of
the I want to see a character who's
truly who was around during that five
years and is truly affected and has like
sometimes a rational emotional responses
to things yeah because they are
traumatized
yeah I think like they they talk like
have lines about trauma about that
five-year Gap but they don't ever really
what the hell are you doing right you're
just like cleaning out the fridge right
now what's going on breakfast you are at
work
you are stalking things
um checking inventory uh yeah scanning
tapes I think um I I would like to I
don't know I'm always down for like the
dark character exploration stuff and and
I feel like audiences have been down for
that too so I wanted a vision really hit
and
and
um what was the I mean I feel I know no
one's really talking about this show but
I think Andor does it pretty well like
Ander is a pretty great show in my
opinion yeah and uh
Multiverse of Madness not really a theme
of grief but stuck to strange feeling
like he lost out on Christine yeah in
those five years I love the the better
the anyways I love you in every universe
Robert
[Laughter]
if you're if you're going to say phase
four has a unifying theme it's
consequences it's the consequences of
the snap and it's the consequences of
everything that happened in endgame I
I'm not going to go through the list but
just about every single project it's not
like a new Standalone character like uh
Moon Knight or Shang Chi it's about the
consequences of what happened
so for all you people who say it seems
like phase four has no plan definitely
has a plan half the projects are about
the Multiverse and they're all about
consequences grief and drama fun the
plan was very obvious since Loki is that
yeah somehow this is all going to
connect you with the Multiverse it's
like it's always been a very often well
even one division when Evan Peters
showed up people like a Multiverse here
baby
or when they revealed
um you know the the power broker and
Falcon a winter soldier and we're all
still talking about that I remember
having a change the MCU forever and
people are still making theories and
breakdowns about it all the time and how
that opened up the door for phase four
we talk about it in our private time all
the time guys about like wow I can't
believe the power broker Falcon Winter
Soldier remember that twist everyone
talks about him Sharon but is it was it
really her though that's the thing like
I don't know if they actually she could
be working for the power broker we just
know that she's not a good guy I'm not
gonna lie I forgot most of what any of
the power Brokers
people sleep on Falcon in the Winter
Soldier man go back and re-watch that
show it's like for sure I think I forgot
all about that it was just right now it
was sandwiched between like those first
four uh actually the first year of
Marvel TV shows were so good and like
the production value was so strong that
it kind of overshadowed everything else
the battery might be about to die in my
camera so if I go away for a second just
because I'm fixing the battery you got
to get a dummy battery man that's what
we have no do you like five I don't know
what that is
stuff with John Walker I thought was
really good yeah that's the stuff I
really remember power broker things I'm
like that was such a big ending and I
feel like there's been
no hype about that at all this is the
best part oh thank God could you fix
your battery too
we'll get our battery going and yeah
um Neva R Williams the delays could be a
good thing we should probably is there
would we should because we do have to
end the stream soon so we should
probably stop allowing super chats to
come in stop your generosity and if you
really want to give any money keep super
chatting you can put that money towards
getting yourselves a shopzeroedition.com
t-shirt today
um but yeah we only got a few more
streams here but thank you I like when
you if we did turn off the super chats
YouTube goes do you understand the
implications of your actions yeah
YouTube's no longer making money I am
never gonna know what you're doing to us
because the YouTube gets like 50 of it
uh the delays can be a good thing but
did they space out releases for delays
as or for a new Spider-Man because they
did this before before for Spider-Man
um yeah yeah I mean things are always
changing there's a lot more behind the
scenes plans than we realize Ryan has
switched angles or cameras
Oh my god wow baby oh my God maybe you
should switch angles
yeah you should have a multi-camera
setup for your one box
in the corner
I love uh
Paul you gotta act like you're not tired
and that you still want to be so tired
you gotta just try to make it look like
you're you're having a great time and
excited because you know what you know
what these delays have done they've just
reminded me I remember when stuff got
delayed during the pandemic and how much
I was panicking and all the anxiety I
was feeling thinking I've got nothing to
cover for the next six months and it's
nice that we've reached a point now
where it's like yeah let them delay it
let them take all the time they need
well there is a time where like all we
were really doing was Marvel stuff
there's more variety home trailer update
yeah
are they in it are they in it are they
in it
here's more evidence to support that
maybe they're in it and now with
Superman and Black Adam it's like The
Rock's just coming out he's like yeah
yeah that's what it is you were right I
lobbied for this I'm pretty much saying
he's in it too without telling you he's
in it but I'm making it pretty clear
he's in it on this planet
that's what he's like yeah that's what
he does Adam is very powerful but if he
was to go to Krypton another planet the
home of someone else
a man who's very super on that planet
they might have some talking to do
but I'm not gonna say anything like I
don't want to spoil anything
yeah he pretty much uh
I don't know I feel like that's that's
one of the weird things about it about
the Superman thing is how
it seems like the rock wanted that to
leak and yeah yeah and now if it's going
to get people in to go see the movie
because I don't know what the buzz about
it you know I don't know if it's it
there's that much interest there is
obviously some interest
um but I don't think it's like
Marvel movie hype you know what I mean
and then so so yeah if if it gets more
people interested in seeing it I think
the Rock's doing the right thing
well it's a gift and a curse being Black
Adam it's a gift and some of those lines
it's definitely a gift but on another
planet
it might be a curse against Superman
what did you say so that's it
um which Marvel Superhero should get a
movie who hasn't gotten one yet in your
opinion that's a good question
Ryan I know you got like 15 answers
ready to go uh
far too many
um Paul's only saying that because she's
English uh well superhero it's kind of
hard to think of a Marvel superhero that
hasn't gotten a movie at this point
um when you run through the list
Squirrel Girl I thought you knew Comics
Ryan I did I do I do pull one out of
your ass right now
Gambit's the most overrated X-Man like
the best X-Men cyclops and I'm so tired
of the movies ignoring This and like
treating them like Cyclops best X-Men
Minecraft that's not the question but
yeah Cyclops I want a cyclops movie you
son of a [ __ ]
what do you want what do you want Paul a
Magneto I was really I love Magneto he's
my favorite
he's my one of my favorite characters of
all time Magneto
um and you know what they actually do do
them right in the movies a lot of the
time he's very conflicted
um obviously he's he lived through the
Holocaust he's seen people get wiped out
he's very paranoid that that's gonna
happen again
um
yeah I love the I think there's so much
stuff they could do with it social
commentary without it feeling woke uh
feeling forced
um yeah I'd love to see Magneto thing
because he's basically someone who go
through the worst things imaginable and
sort of becomes a villain because of it
but he's also a hero to many people
you know he's a he's a freedom fighter
that there's thousands of mutants that
feel persecuted and they look to Magneto
to be their voice
um so yeah I think they could do
something really fascinating with him
but anyway my actual answer is Dr Doom
Dr Doom's by far my favorite comic book
villain one of my favorite comic book
characters he's one of the few villains
kind of like Magneto who could support a
movie and if you see where he kind of
like he starts off you know there's some
great Comics like uh limited series
about dude's childhood and stuff if you
start off kind of like Anakin Skywalker
and you show this like little kid with
the purest of intentions who was
persecuted uh as a child and had raw
talent and really thought that Raw
Talent would help him and his people get
out of where they were and just the
system and greed and everything pushes
him down and he makes this promise
that's never going to happen again
because I am going to be better than
everything and I am going to fix it I am
going to fix the world and you know not
to keep the Darth Vader comparisons
going too much but it obviously ends up
in an iron suit except unlike Vader he
chooses that life for himself because he
wants to detach himself from Humanity
because he whether he knows or not he
won't let himself ever get attached to
anybody again after he loses his mom
it's a great origin story Great
Character and he would be such a better
villain and fantastic for part two if we
got a setup movie of just Doctor Doom
I don't think Ryan's battery died I'm
pretty sure he set up a teleprompter yes
and he went to find that Doom action
figure okay now actually the Doom action
figure just fell off the wall earlier I
this is a really good when his mask
comes off he's got he's supposed to have
a pistol but it fell out it's in the
closet I think and he sits on his little
castle I really like great answers we
know Doom's coming I'd like a Magneto
movie I think Magneto should be played
by LaShawna Lynch just to make everyone
happy yes
Amanda Doherty I love all you guys have
a great day well we love you love you
back that's nice thank you
it's a lovely profile pic again very
friendly smile emotionless does not know
how to receive a compliment just I just
feel like I'm being really rehearsed you
know I mean you like you go off into the
usual Spiel of oh thanks so much I
appreciate that so much and does it I
feel very fake doing it but I do I
really appreciate it
I just feel like I'm almost being like
I've done it so many times that it's all
it almost feels rehearsed
so don't give any of us any money let's
just be silent and take that in no I do
I do really appreciate it taking the
darkness
from
Heavies
I don't want to say thank you because it
just sounds No I do want to say thank
you my face isn't gonna
but I need that what will be your rating
for Disney plus MCU content mine is Loki
werewolf Miss Marvel Wanda Vision Falcon
Moon Knight Hawkeye Shield all right I'm
gonna spitball this really fast everyone
spitballing I'm gonna say one division
uh werewolf finite Loki uh uh Moon
Knight Falcon Winter Soldier uh Miss
Marvel
She-Hulk Hawkeye no no no flip no no she
okay it's a daredevil episode yeah
someone's just said Paul is Doom which I
appreciate sure yeah all right I got you
I had to write mine down
One Division Loki Loki and her Soldier
werewolf Hawkeye Moon Knight what if
which isn't on this list She-Hulk and Ms
Marvel
yeah mine would be just looking at this
guy's list rearranging it uh Loki number
one yeah number two would be yeah
werewolf By Night number three would be
Falcon in the winter so oh no sorry one
Loki two one division three werewolf for
Falcon in the Winter Soldier five Moon
Knight six Miss Marvel seven what if
then Hawkeye and She-Hulk last
yeah eight women John
Loki uh one division werewolf Falcon
Miss Marvel Moon Knight
She-Hulk Hawkeye
no what if
what if uh
Hawkeye those last two episodes of what
if are really really good
doctor strange episode is one of the
best Marvel animated things yeah ever
existing the captain cutter one don't
[ __ ] don't forget Captain
I get paid by Marvel every time
um I want them to go broader with
whatever thank you thank you uh I mean
thank you from Brian gone and I not Paul
uh Anthony Solis truly enjoying the
stream wanted to take this moment to say
a big thank you to the four of you and
all your hard work well no one's working
as hard as John these no it's these
three these guys
Humphrey over here and Justin attache
heavy spoilers was mainly inspired by
John before starting up his channel and
um
he's dead
what oh really
damn really ah look at that yeah yeah
really you'll go type that in John
you'll go Lansbury for this cranberry
because it's dinner she wrote it's a
weird heaven
you really that's the way when did she
pass away this morning
just now one hour it used to be 96. wow
[Music]
I'm gonna have to go soon guys
I gotta go watch Murder She Wrote I'm
feeling nostalgic now yeah break down
okay break down we're almost at the
we're at the tail end I promise there's
only a couple more left Quinton Anthony
Anderson
how do you all feel about the MCU delays
announced
attack today before them before them we
covered them they were great take your
time do it right take your time get
those VFX correct give your artists a
human amount of time yeah oh we got a
massive super chat today thank you so
much thank you to everyone donating as
well thank you to everyone yeah
absolutely even if you haven't donated
us A-Okay just present you with the way
the world is right now we any money we
appreciate it Ronaldo make a whiskey
Hall's just trying to bounce back from
his okay just sending support smash that
like thank you guys so much thank you
and all that's that's incredibly
generous thank you absolutely fine thank
you man and um I haven't found my
Daredevil beanie I'm convinced one of
the guys here on the stream took it uh
Ronaldo thank you thank you and then uh
hey guys just want to say thank you for
all the from zenix one of the amazing
content recently and the Zero edition
back in the shirt feels so nice when I
get nipples yeah it doesn't skate it
doesn't burn doesn't chafe your your
sensitive areas no I I wanted I made
sure it was going to be nipple resilient
on that nipple Thrills nipple Thrills
hell swimming for the holiday spec I
think holiday special thank you for the
Super Chat for the Guardians you think
Groot will be Marvel's stenna Satan will
be Marvel's uh
uh yeah that'd be good
maybe an actual Santa and think ego that
can be Santa oh we should get Kurt
Russell yeah
[Laughter]
yeah Guardians of the Christmas
Chronicles
um yeah I'm pretty sure we don't we
always feel weird ending a stream
without acknowledging the super chess
but I'm pretty sure that was everyone
here
um and thank you guys so much for yeah
that was it thank you guys so much for
everything here and um I want to thank
this was a bit of a workaround to
schedule this and I'm glad we gotta do
it guys so Paul thank you for joining us
so late at night heavy spoilers Channel
slowly been dying day by day but I feel
like you know he's on he's on the up and
coming if he just persists he can break
through that mold and then eventually
thanks for coming everyone much
appreciated I'm just reading the
comments and build saying bye Paul bye
bye and
um Ryan thank you for being you
um no I really think you should rewrite
that whole novel uh I I don't feel like
it's I think you need to rework the
foundation a little bit and perhaps
change the characters up you know I'm
just saying but uh yeah guys so sort of
support go check out their shirt shop
zeroedition.com you got the how do we
how do we remove this just flash it on
screen really quick I just need to
remove this Paul bear with me I could
feel like don't worry everyone's trying
to go find it say hi current comment
there we go boom uh so Paul why don't
you flash your shirt on screen one more
time better call baby
and then we got ourselves Ryan Airy with
his not the Beast shirt yes that's right
and reject citizens you can get yourself
a citizen king shirt um this was fun did
you guys have fun let's do it again
all right guys we'll see you all soon
peace out reject Nation thank you so
much for your support and uh check us
out shopzeroedition.com much love for
everybody thanks guys see you guys
done
bye we're still alive we're gonna do
like a hey thanks for stopping by oh wow
it's still us Paul it's just us real
reject says live and it's just us is
this wait did this happen are we in
control of their Channel now we are I'm
on YouTube this is just us Paul
until we hit the off button
this is what are you doing
start dropping copyright songs
everywhere
we're leaving for real now
I don't know what I'm doing we're gonna
actually end the broadcast love you all
good good day goodbye